vegas is coming back to life and we're
all ecstatic to see the city we know and
love
after months and months of covet
closures really a year our positivity
rate
steady decline but experts do say some
are getting a bit too relaxed too soon
they worry if we don't stay vigilant
it could possibly derail our path to
hurt immunity
and eventual normalcy sasha loftus
joining us live from the las vegas strip
with more on this hi sasha
good evening brian everyone really is so
excited to see our strip and our entire
city
come back to life but some may be
getting a little
too excited too soon and not following
those restrictions
the expert i spoke with tonight said
it's important to remember
the pandemic isn't over just yet
it's easy to see vegas is bouncing back
i love vegas it's coming back to life
covet positivity rates are hitting
record lows
businesses bars and casinos are opening
as long as everybody's
safe and no complaints
it's all great news after an incredibly
difficult year
but are some throwing caution to the
wind too soon
things are heading in the right
direction but it doesn't mean we're at
our destination yet unlv assistant
professor of public health brian labis
says though restrictions have eased
there's still a risk of transmission we
can go out we can do things more often
we can gather more often but we still
need to wear masks to basically
counteract that risk that comes along
with all of those activities
the cdc reported a 7 percent uptick in
cases across the nation this week
and labis says scenes like this have the
potential to derail our progress
right now we basically have a race
between the virus and vaccination
we want to get everybody vaccinated but
we could see a surge before we get to
that point
so if we want to see that slice of
normalcy soon
you take a sip put your mask right back
on take a smoke put your mask right back
on
it's time to push through to a better
brighter future
now it's important to remember that our
mask mandate here in nevada in las vegas
is still in place now the nevada gaming
control board did also send a reminder
last week to casinos across the city and
the county that
that pools must stay at 50 percent
capacity and mass muppet must be warm
and
worn at all times rather unless you're
swimming actively or eating or drinking
because of those videos that we showed
you circulating last weekend around
march madness celebrations
reporting live in the las vegas strip
tonight sasha loftis 8 news now